في ظل المخاوف من تخطي سكان العالم 8
مليارات نسمه وما اذا كانت موارد الارض
ستكفي هذه الاعداد من البشر دراسه تثير
قلقا من الجانب الاخر مستقبل البشريه في
خطر والسبب الانخفاض المتسارع في تركيز
الحيوانات المنويه وخصوبه الرجل المتراجع
الدراسه التي نشرت في مجله هيومن
ريبرودكشن تقول ان عدد الحيوانات المنويه
خفض بحوالي اثنين وخمسين في المئه في جميع
انحاء العالم بين عام 1973
و2018 الازمه ان نسبه التراجع السنويه
تزداد بمقدار حيث وصلت الى اثنين فاصل 64%
بعد عام 2020
بحسب الباحثين السمنه تناول الاطعمه
المصنعه وقله النشاط البدني من العوامل
المؤثره بشكل مباشر على تراجع الخصوبه عند
الذكور
[موسيقى]
انا في الاستوديو ينضم الى استشاري امراض
المسالك البوليه دكتور ميشيل الجبور دكتور
يسعد صباحك
المستقبل البشريه في خطر هل بالفعل طبيا
نشهد تراجع في خصوبه الرجال بنسبه فوق 50%
جدا
الوفيات عن ما تقل يعني اذا بنرجع شويه
مئه سنه الى الوراء معدل عمر الانسان كان
ما يتجاوز ال 35 40 سنه هلا معدل عامل
الانسان 85 سنه اذا الوفيات عن مدخل هلا
الولدات عمه تكثر او تقل بحسب البلدان
يعني بنلاقي في بلدين نسبه الخصوبه فيها
كثير مرتفعه وهن همم البلدان يا اللي هي
تعتبر العالم الثالث غير المتقدمه في
الوقت اللي فيه البلدان المتقدمه عامل له
نسبه الخصوبه فيها حتى عملت يعني عم
تتراجع الى الورقه اه طيب دكتور هناك من
همم يرجع عن اسباب الى المواد الكيماويه
التعرض للاطعمه الفائقه المعالجه السمنه
التدخين كل الرجال اللي عم بيشوفونا ما هي
نصائح همم تنصحهم فيها حتى يعني حافظوا
على صحتهم الانجابيه
لك اول سبب اذا بدنا نكون واقعيين هو
التقدم في العمر عند الزواج يعني هذا
السبب الرئيسي ليش هلا الخصوبه هي اقل من
ما كانت عليها بالماضي يعني اذا انا اقول
نحن واحد من ثمانيه كابلز هلا بعصرنا
الحالي بواجه مشكله في الانجاب واحد على
ثمانيه تقريبا
كانت عندنا اياها اذا في عندنا تطور ملفت
بنسبه
او عدم القدره همم
همم العمر مثل ما قلت يعني احنا الرجل اول
المراه هني بيكونوا بعز الخصوصي تبعيتهم
بعمر ال20 مين بقى بيجوز بعمر ال 20 سو
الموضوع عم يصير في الزواج بعمره متقدم
اكثر وكل ما نتقدم بالعمر كل ما تخف قدره
الخصوصيه هلا السبب الاخر الاساسي او
نسميه الانفايرمنت لتوكسينز او التلوث
المجتمع يعني احنا الحضاره تعادل تلوث نحن
كل شيء عني بنشوفه من معامل من من
تكنولوجي كل هذا يؤدي الارتفاع في نسبه
التلوث
توكسينز اضيف اليه نمط الحياه صار نمط
يعني كانه من زمان على العالم
فلاحين يعني اجمالا موجودين كل النهار
اوكي
في دوالي عند الرجل ودوالي الخصيه كمان
انا بتاثر على الانجاب او عم يكونوا اوفس
ووركير قاعدين كل النهار ورق المكتب اللي
عم يؤدي الى افراط في السمنه يعني عم يزيد
وزنهم اوريك عم يصير في عندنا سترس بيلعب
دور
والتدخين طيب دكتور ميشال اليوم هل ممكن
احنا ننصح كل رجل صار عمره 25 يعمل مثلا
شو رايك بها الفكره
همم انا فيني اقول في نعدلها شويه انا
بقول ما ننطر لل يست يتزوج ويصير عم
يحاولوا يجيبوا اولاد تيعملوا سبرنتستكنك
انا نصيحه
ضروري الثاني
بس على فكره هاي المره بس قبل ما نكمل
دكتور فكره انه الموضوع وعناوين عريضه عم
نحكي انه تراجع خصوبه الرجل واذا تمتع مين
هذه المساله هذا سيخفف ضغط على كثير من
النساء لانه دائما الثقافه العربيه
تلوم المراه يعني المشكله فيك بعد عدم
الانجاب فاذا تم تعميم هذه المساله هنا
انتصرت النساء
بس اذا في عندنا 100 شخص عنده مشكله هي
تقريبا نصفه بنصف يعني المشكله هي من
المراه 40% من الرجل 40% و20% سوا ما حدا
يقول انه همم الموضوع له علاقه اكثر او
الرجل اكثر هو اجمالا 50 50
يعني الاعضاء التناسليه
ينجب لعمرو متقدم جدا 60 70 اوقات 80 سنه
بس
الامور اللي بتتغير بحياه الرجل اليوميه
بتاثر عليك كثير فضيعتك للاستفيد منهم نحن
بنعرف الشباب مثلا بيروحوا على الجيم اوكي
احنا بننصح شباب بيعملوا حركات رياضيه بس
الشيء اللي ما بيعرفوه شباب هني بالجم انه
البروتين اللي عم ياخذوا طيب
صفر الشباب
احنا اكيد بنتمنى السلامه لكل رجال العالم
لانه البشريه تحتاج السيده البشريه تحتاج
المزيد من الاشخاص من حيث النوعيه وليس
العدد طبعا المعلومات التركيه